construit en 2006 le nouveau bâtiment
des archives d'eure-et-loir dispose
d'une vaste salle de lecture c'est le
deuxième épisode de notre feuilleton
regardez c'est une salle lumineuse
confortablement aménagé d'ici là du est
imprenable sur la cathédrale de chartres
on entendrait presque des mouches voler
un silence quasi monacale rompu par
quelques incursions donc l'article n'est
pas photocopiant moi ce que je vous
conseille au plus vite c'est de
contacter soit par mail soit par
téléphone
la mairie du coudray et celle ci vous
délivrera directement une copie
intégrale de votre de l'acte de décès de
votre maman des conseils des
recommandations les sollicitations des
lecteurs sont parfois inattendus
les archives dispose d'un patrimoine
encyclopédique en matière de presse
locale nous arrivons à la presse
quotidienne locale locales surtout pas
national national s'est scellée
bibliothèque qui les concernent en
général donc la presse plutôt local on a
toute la collection depuis depuis des
siècles maintenant
donc voilà
si le document est abîmée c'est le
lecteur qui en est responsable
en fait on fait des sondages aléatoires
et dès l'instant où on suppose qu'il
peut y avoir un risque pour un document
on va avoir le lecteur et on lui dit de
faire plus attention à ce qu'il est en
train de faire notamment quand on
consulte des journaux on évite de lécher
son doigt vous savez pour tourner les
pages
puisque ça la salive c'est très nocif
pour pour les journaux notamment puisque
la salif et autres acides et donc du
coup endommagé le document dès que les
documents sont restitués ils vont
parcourir un dédale de couloirs avant
d'être rangés dans les sous sols à
température ambiante 20 degrés plus
quand elle imagine les lecteurs sont
légion à faire des recherches sur la
généalogie vous être monté jusqu'à
quelle année mais pour certains ce camp
en 1672 mon nom particulièrement où ils
sont nés sont mariés ou sont décédés
principalement dans le département
quel est l'intérêt une passion de savoir
bas comme tout veut tous les jours je
l'espère des combien pour son risque où
va la généalogie à sa dette
l'histoire aussi et là je suis en train
de travailler sur l'histoire de sharon
là où j'habite et donc je cherche je
pensais pas d'ailleurs trouvé le temps
de choses et donc j'arrive à la fin
bientôt
quelle finalité publication d'un livre
au total 800 électeurs inscrits et 4
millions de vues par an sur le site
internet des archives départementales
d'eure et loir